[Music]
New York September 30th CP flash
ambassador Halliwell died here today the
end came suddenly as the Ambassador was
alone in his study there's something
ungodly about these night wire jobs you
sit up here on the top floor of a
skyscraper and listening to the whispers
of a civilization New York London
Calcutta Bombay
Singapore there your next-door
neighbours after the street lights go
dim and the world has gone to sleep
alone in the quiet hours between 2:00
and 4:00 the receiving operators doze
over their Sounders and the news comes
in fires and disasters and suicides
murders crowds catastrophes sometimes an
earthquake with a casualty list as long
as your arm the night wire man takes it
down almost in his sleep picking it off
on his typewriter with one finger once
in a long time you prick up your ears
and listen you've heard of someone you
knew in Singapore Halifax or Paris long
ago maybe they've been promoted but more
probably they've been murdered or
drowned perhaps they just decided to
quit and took some bizarre way out made
it interesting enough to get in the news
but that doesn't happen often most of
the time you sit and doze and tap tap on
your typewriter and wish you were home
in bed sometimes though queer things
happen one did the other night and I
haven't got over it yet I wish I could
you see I handle the night managers desk
in a western seaport town what the name
is doesn't matter there is or rather was
only one night operator on my staff a
fellow named John Morgan about 40 years
of age I should say and a sober
hard-working sort
he was one of the best operators I ever
knew what is known as a double man that
means he could handle two instruments at
once and type the stories on different
typewriters at the same time he was one
of the three men I ever knew who could
do it consistently
hour after hour and never make a mistake
generally we used only one wire at night
but sometimes when it was late and the
news was coming fast the Chicago and
Denver stations would open a second wire
and then Morgan would do his stuff he
was a wizard a mechanical automatic
wizard which functioned marvelously but
was without imagination on the night of
the 16th he complained of feeling tired
it was the first and last time I had
ever heard him say a word about himself
and I had known him for three years
it was just three o'clock and we were
running only one wire I was nodding over
the reports at my desk and not paying
much attention to him when he spoke Jim
he said does it feel close in here to
you why I know John I answered but I'll
open a window if you like never mind he
said I reckon I'm just a little tired
that was all that was said and I went on
working every ten minutes or so I would
walk over and take a pile of copy that
had stacked up neatly beside the
typewriter as the messages were printed
out in triplicate it must have been 20
minutes after he spoke that I noticed he
had opened up the other wire and was
using both typewriters I thought it was
a little unusual as there was nothing
very hot coming in on my next trip I
picked up the copy from both machines
and took it back to my desk to sort out
the duplicates the first wire was
running out the usual sort of stuff and
I just looked over it hurriedly then I
turned to the second pile of copy I
remembered it particularly because the
story was from a town I had never heard
of ziba Co here is the dispatch I saved
a duplicate of it from our files ziba Co
September 16th CP bulletin
the heaviest mist in the history of the
city settled over the town at 4 o'clock
yesterday afternoon all traffic has
stopped and the mist hangs like a pall
over everything lights of ordinary
intensity failed to pierce the fog which
is constantly growing heavier scientists
here are unable to agree as to the cause
and the local weather bureau states that
the like has never occurred before in
the history of the city at 7:00 p.m.
last night the municipal authorities
more that was all there was nothing out
of the ordinary at a bureau headquarters
but as I say I noticed the story because
of the name of the town it must have
been 15 minutes later that I went over
for another batch of copy
Morgan was slumped down in his chair and
it switched his green electric light
shades said that the gleam missed his
eyes and hit only the top of the two
typewriters only the usual stuff was in
the right hand pile but the left hand
batch carried another story from ziba Co
all press dispatches come in takes
meaning that parts of many different
stories are strung along together
perhaps with but a few paragraphs of
each coming through at a time the second
story was marked add fog here is the
copy at 7:00 p.m. the fog had increased
noticeably all lights were now invisible
and the town was shrouded in pitch
darkness as a peculiarities of the
phenomenon the fog is accompanied by a
sickly odour comparable to nothing yet
experienced here below that in customary
pres fashion was the hour 327 and the
initials of the operator JM there was
only one other story in the pile from
the second wire here it is second add Z
Baku fog accounts as to the origin of
the mist differ greatly among the most
unusual is that of the sexton of the
local church who groped his way to
headquarters at a hysterical condition
and declared that the fog originated in
the village churchyard it was first
visible as a soft gray blanket clinging
to the earth above the graves he stated
then it began to rise higher and higher
a subterranean breeze seemed to blow it
in billows which split up and then
joined together again fog phantoms
writhing in anguish twisted the mist
into queer forms and figures and then in
the very thick midst of the mass
something moved I turned and ran from
the accursed spot behind me I heard
screams coming from the houses bordering
on the graveyard
although the sexton story is generally
discredited a party has left to
investigate immediately after telling
his story the sexton collapsed and is
now in a local hospital unconscious
queer story wasn't it not that we aren't
used to it
for a lot of unusual stories come in
over the wire but for some reason or
other perhaps because it was so quiet
that night the report of the fog made a
great impression on me
it was almost with dread that I went
over to the waiting piles of copy Morgan
did not move and the only sound in the
room was the tap tap of the sounders it
was ominous nerve-racking there was
another story from Z Boko in the pile of
copy I seized on it anxiously new lead
ZB Co fog CP the rescue party which went
out at 11:00 p.m. to investigate a weird
story of the origin of a fog which since
late yesterday has shrouded the city in
darkness has failed to return another
and larger party has been dispatched
meanwhile the fog has if possible grown
heavier it seeped through the cracks and
the doors and fills the atmosphere with
a depressing odor of decay it is
oppressive terrifying bearing with it a
subtle impression of things long dead
residents of the city have left their
homes and gathered in a local church
where the priests are holding services
of prayer the scene is beyond
description grown folk and children are
alike terrified and many are almost
beside themselves with fear amid the
wisps of vapor which partly veiled the
Church auditorium an old priest is
praying for the welfare of his flock
they alternately wail and cross
themselves from the outskirts of the
city may be heard cries of unknown
voices they echo through the fog and qui
run cadenced minor keys the sounds
resemble nothing so much as wind
whistling through a gigantic tunnel but
the night is calm and there is no wind
the second rescue party more I am a calm
man and never in a dozen years spent
with the wires have I been known to
become excited but despite myself I rose
from my chair and walked to the window
could I be mistaken or far down in the
canyons of the city beneath me did I see
a faint trace of fog it was all
imagination in the pressroom the click
of the Sounders seemed to have raised
the tempo of their tune morgen alone had
not stirred from his chair his head sunk
between his shoulders he tapped the
dispatches out on the typewriters with
one finger of each hand
he looked asleep but no endlessly
efficiently the two machines rattled off
line after line as relentlessly and
effortlessly as death itself there was
something about the monotonous movement
of the typewriter keys that fascinated
me I walked over and stood behind his
chair reading over his shoulder the type
as it came into being word by word ah
here was another flash ziba Co CP there
will be no more bulletins from this
office the impossible has happened no
messages have come into this room for 20
minutes we are cut off from the outside
and even the streets below us I will
stay with the wire until the end it is
the end indeed since 4 p.m. yesterday
the fog has hung over the city following
reports from the sexton of the local
church to rescue parties were sent out
to investigate conditions on the
outskirts of the city neither party has
ever returned nor was any word received
from them it is quite certain now that
they will never return for my instrument
I can gaze down on the city beneath me
from the position of this room on the
13th floor nearly the entire city can be
seen now I can see only a thick blanket
of blackness where customarily our
lights in life I fear greatly that the
wailing cry is heard constantly from the
outskirts of the
city are the death cries of the
inhabitants they are constantly
increasing in volume and are approaching
the center of the city the fog yet hangs
over everything if possible it is even
heavier than before but the conditions
have changed instead of an opaque
impenetrable wall of odorous vapour
there now swirls and Rives the shapeless
mass and contortions of almost human
agony now and again the mass parts and I
catch a brief glimpse of the streets
below people are running to and fro
screaming and despair a vast bedlam of
sound flies up to my window and above
all is the immense whistling of unseen
and unfelt winds the fog has again swept
over the city and the whistling is
coming closer and closer it is now
directly beneath me God an instant ago
the mist opened and I caught a glimpse
of the streets below the fog is not
simply vapor it lives by the side of
each moaning and weeping human is a
companion figure an aura of strange and
very colored hues how the shapes cling
each to a living thing the men and women
are down flat on their faces the fog
figures caress them lovingly they are
kneeling beside them they are but I dare
not tell it the prone and writhing
bodies have been stripped of their
clothing they are being consumed
piecemeal a merciful wall of hot
steaming vapour has swept over the whole
scene I can see no more beneath me the
wall of vapor is changing colors it
seems to be lighted by internal fires no
it isn't I've made a mistake
the colors are from above reflections
from the sky look up look up the whole
sky is in flames colors as yet unseen by
man or demon the flames are moving they
have started to intermix the colors are
rearranging themselves they are so
brilliant that my eyes burn they're a
long way off now they have begun to
swirl to circle in and out twisting in
intricate designs and patterns the
lights are racing each with each a
kaleidoscope of unearthly brilliance I
have made a discovery
there is nothing harmful in the lights
they radiate force and friendliness
almost cheeriness but by their very
strength they hurt as I look they are
swinging closer and closer a million
miles at each jump millions of miles
with the speed of light it is the light
of quintessence of all light beneath it
the fog melts into a jeweled mist
radiant rainbow-colored of a thousand
varied spectra I can see the streets why
they're filled with people the lights
are coming closer they are all around me
I'm enveloped I the message stopped
abruptly the wire to Z Boko was dead
beneath my eyes in the narrow circle of
light from under the green lampshade the
black printing no longer spun itself
letter by letter across the page the
room seemed filled with a solemn quiet a
silence vaguely impressive powerful I
looked down at Morgan his hands had
dropped nervously at his side's while
his body had hunched over peculiarly I
turned the lampshade back throwing
lights squarely in his face his eyes
were staring fixed filled with a sudden
foreboding I stepped beside him and
called Chicago on the wire
after a second the sounder clicked it's
answer why but there was something wrong
Chicago was reporting that wire 2 had
not been used throughout the evening
Morgan I shouted Morgan wake up it isn't
true
someone has been hoaxing us why in my
eagerness I grasped him by the shoulder
his body was quite cold Morgan had been
dead for hours could it be that his
sensitized brain and automatic fingers
had continued to record impressions even
after the end I shall never know for I
shall never again handle the night shift
search in a world atlas discloses no
town of Xebec oh whatever it was that
killed John Morgan will forever remain a
mystery
past the sleeping city the river sweeps
along its left bank the old canal creeps
I did not intend that to be poetry
although the scene is poetic sombrely
gruesomely poetic like the poems of Poe
- well I know it - often have I walked
over the grass-grown path beside the
reflections of black trees and tumble
down shacks and distant factory chimneys
and the sluggish waters that moved so
slowly and ceased to move at all I shall
be called mad and I shall be a suicide I
shall take no pains to cover up my trail
or to hide the thing that I shall do
what will it matter afterward what they
say of me if they knew the truth if they
could vision even dimly the beings with
whom I have consorted if the faintest
realization might be theirs of the thing
I am becoming and of the fate from which
I am saving their City then they would
call me a great hero but it does not
matter what they call me as I have said
before let me write down the things I am
about to write down and let them be
taken as they will be taken for the last
ravings of a madman the city will be in
mourning for the thing I shall have done
but it's mourning will be of no
consequence beside that other fate from
which I shall have saved it I have
always had a taste for nocturnal
prowling we as a race have grown too
intelligent to take seriously any of the
old instinctive fears that preserved us
through preceding generations our sole
remaining salvation then has come to be
our tendency to travel in herds we
wander at night but our objective is
somewhere on the brightly lighted
streets or still somewhere where men do
not go alone when we travel far afield
it is in company few of my acquaintances
few in the whole city here would care to
ramble at midnight over the grass-grown
path I have spoken of not because they
would fear to do so but because such
things are not being done well it is
dangerous to differ individually from
one's fellows it is dangerous to wander
from the beaten road
and the fears that guarded the race and
the dawn of time and through the
centuries were real fears founded on
reality a month ago I was a stranger
here I had just taken my first position
I was graduated from college only three
months before in the spring I was lonely
and likely to remain so for sometime for
I've always been of a solitary nature
making friends slowly I had received one
invitation out to visit the camp of a
fellow employee in the firm for which I
worked a camp which was located on the
farther side of the wide river the side
across from the city in the canal where
the bank was high and steep and heavily
wooded and little tents blossomed all
along the water's edge at night these
camps were a string of sparkling lights
and tiny leaping campfires and the
tinkle of music carried faintly far
across the calmly flowing water that far
bank of the river was no place for an
eccentric solitary man to love but the
near bank which would have been an
eyesore to the campers had not the river
been so wide the near Bank attracted me
from my first glimpse of it we embarked
in a motorboat at some distance
downstream and swept up along the near
bank and then out and across the current
I turned my eyes backward the murk of
stagnant water that was the canal the
jumble of low buildings beyond it the
lonely low-lying wastes of the narrow
strip of land between canal and river
the dark scattered trees growing there I
intended to see more of these things
that weekend bored me but I repaid
myself no later than Monday evening the
first evening when I was back in the
city alone and free I ate a solitary
dinner immediately after leaving the
office I went to my room and slept from
7:00 until nearly midnight I waken
naturally then for my whole heart was
set on exploring the alluring solitude I
had discovered I dressed slipped out of
the house and into the street started
the motor in my roadster which I had
left parked at the curb and drove
through the lighted streets
I left behind that part of town which
was thick with vehicles carrying people
home from their evening engagements and
began to thread my way through darker
and narrower streets once I had to back
out of a cul-de-sac and once I had to
detour around a closed block this part
of town was not alluring even to me it
was dismal without being solitary but
when I had parked my car on a rough
cobbled street that ran directly down
into the inky waters of the canal and
crossed a narrow bridge I was repaid a
few minutes set my feet on the old toe
path where mules had drawn river boats
up and down only a year or so ago across
the canal now as I walked up stream at a
swinging pace the miserable shacks where
miserable people lived seemed to march
with me and then fell behind they looked
like places in which murders might be
committed every one of them the bridge I
had crossed was near the end of the city
going north as the canal marked its
western extremity ten minutes of walking
and the dismal shacks were quite a
distance behind the river was farther
away and the strip of wasteland much
wider and more wooded and tall trees
across the canal marched with me as the
evil-looking houses had done before far
and faint the sound of a bell in the
city reached my ears it was midnight
I stopped enjoyed the desolation around
me
it had the savor I had expected and
hoped for I stood for some time looking
up at the sky watching the low drift of
heavy clouds which were visible in the
dull reflected glow from distant lights
in the heart of the city so that they
appeared to have a lurid phosphorescence
of their own the ground under my feet on
the contrary was utterly devoid of light
I had felt my way carefully knowing the
edge of the canal partly by instinct
partly by the even more perfect
blackness of the water in it and even
holding pretty well to the path because
it was perceptibly sunken below the
ground beside it
now as I stood motionless in this spot
my eyes up cast my mind adrift with
strange fancies suddenly my feelings of
satisfaction and well-being gave way to
something different
fear was an emotion unknown to me for
those things which make men fear I had
always loved a graveyard at night was to
me a charming place for a stroll in
meditation but now the roots of my hair
seemed to move up right on my head and
along all the length of my spine I was
conscious of a prickling tingling
sensation such as my forefathers may
have felt in the jungle with a hair on
their back stood up as the hair of my
head was doing now also I was afraid to
move and I knew that there were eyes
upon me and that was why I was afraid to
move I was afraid of those eyes afraid
to see them to look into them all this
while I stood perfectly still my face up
tilted toward the sky but after a
terrible mental effort I mastered myself
slowly slowly with an attempt to
propitiate the owner of the unseen eyes
by my casual manner I lowered my own eye
looked straight ahead at the softly
swaying silhouette of the treetops
across the canal as they moved gently in
the cool night wind at the mass of
blackness that was those trees and the
opposite shore at the shiny blackness
were the reflections of the clouds
glinted vaguely and disappeared that was
the canal and again I raised my eyes a
little for just across the canal where
the shadows masked most heavily there
was that at which I must look more
closely and now as I grew accustomed to
the greater blackness and my pupils
expanded I dimly discerned the contours
of an old boat or barge half sunken in
the water an old abandoned canal boat
but was I dreaming or was there a white
clad figure seated on the roof of the
low cabin aft a pale heart-shaped face
gleaming strangely at me from the
darkness the glow of two eyes seeming to
light up the face and to detach it from
the darkness surely there could be no
doubt as to the eyes they shone as the
eyes of animals shine in the dark with a
phosphorescent gleam and a glimmer of
red well I had heard that some human
eyes have that quality at night but what
a place for a human being to be a girl
too
I was sure that daintily heart-shaped
face was the face of a girl surely I was
seeing it clearer and clearer either
because my eyes were growing more
accustomed to peering into the deeper
shadows or because of that
phosphorescence in the eyes that stared
back at me I raised my voice softly not
to break too much the stillness of the
night hello who's there are you lost or
marooned and can I help there was a
little pause I was conscious of a soft
lapping at my feet a stronger night wind
had sprung up and was ruffling the dark
waters I had been over warm and where it
struck me the perspiration turned cold
on my body so that I shivered
uncontrollably you can stay and talk a
while if you will I'm lonely but not
lost I I live here I could hardly
believe my ears
the voice was little more than a whisper
but it had carried clearly a girl's
voice sure enough and she lived there in
an old abandoned canal boat half
submerged in the stagnant water you are
not alone there no not alone my father
lives here with me but he is deaf and he
sleeps soundly did the night wind blow
still colder as though it came to us
from some unseen frozen sea or was there
something in her tone that chilled me
even as a strange attraction drew me
toward her
I wanted to draw near to her to see
closely the pale heart-shaped face to
lose myself in the bright eyes that I
had seen shining in the darkness I
wanted to hold her in my arms to find
her mouth with mine to kiss it with a
start I realized the nature of my
thoughts and for an instant lost all
thought in surprise never in my 22 years
that I felt love before my fancies had
been otherwise directed a mosque rune
fallen gravestone was a dearer thing to
me to contemplate than the fairest face
in all the world yet surely what I felt
now was love I took a reckless step near
the edge of the bank could I come over
to you I begged it's warm and I don't
mind a wedding it's late I know but I
would give a great deal to sit beside
you and talk if only for a few minutes
before I go back to town it's a lonely
place here for a girl like you to live
your father should not mind if you
exchanged a few words with someone
occasionally was it the
unconventionality of my request that
made her next words sound like a
long-drawn shudder of protest there was
a strangeness in the tones of her voice
that held me wondering every time she
spoke no oh no you must not swim across
then could I come tomorrow or some day
soon in the daytime and would you let me
come on board then or would you come on
shore and talk to me perhaps not in the
daytime never in the daytime again the
intensity of her low tone negation held
me spellbound it was not her sense of
the impropriety of the hour then that
had dictated her manner for surely any
girl with a slightest sense of the
fitness of things would rather have a
tryst by daytime than after midnight yet
there was an inference in her last words
that if I came again it should be again
at night still feeling the spell that
had enthralled me as one does not forget
the presence of a drug in the air that
is stealing one senses even when those
senses begin to wander and to busy
themselves with other things i yet spoke
shortly
why do you say never in the daytime do
you mean that I may come more than this
once at night though now you won't let
me cross the canal to you at the expense
of my own clothes and you won't put down
your plank or drawbridge or whatever you
come on shore with and talk to me here
for only a moment I'll come again if
you'll let me talk to you instead of
calling across the water I'll come again
any time you will let me day or night I
don't care I want to come to you but I
only ask you to explain if I came in the
daytime and met your father wouldn't
that be the best thing to do then we
could be really acquainted we could be
friends in the night time my father
sleeps in the daytime I sleep how could
I talk to you or introduce you to my
father then if you came on board this
boat in the daytime you would find my
father and you would be sorry as for me
I would be sleeping I could never
introduce you to my father do you see
you sleep soundly you and your father
again there was peak in my voice
yes we sleep soundly and always at
different times always at different
times we are on guard one of us is
always on guard
we have been hardly used down there in
your city and we have taken refuge here
and we are always always on guard
the resentment vanished from my breast
and I felt my heart go out to her I knew
she was so pale so pitiful in the night
my eyes were learning better and better
how to pierce the darkness they were
giving me a more definite picture of my
companion if I could think of her as a
companion between myself and whom
stretched the black water the sadness of
the lonely scene the perfection of the
solitude itself these things contributed
to her pitifulness
Then There was that strangeness of
atmosphere of which even yet I had only
partly taken note there was a strange
shivering chill which yet did not seem
like the healthful chill of a cool
evening in fact it did not prevent me
from feeling the oppression of the night
which was unusually sultry it was like a
little breath of deadly cold that came
and went and yet did not alter the
temperature of the air itself as the
small ripples on the surface of water do
not concern the water even a foot down
and even that was not all there was an
unwholesome smell about the night a dank
moldy smell that might have been the
very breath of death and decay even I
the connoisseur and all things dismal
and unwholesome tried to keep my mind
from dwelling over much upon that smell
what it must be to live breathing it
constantly in I could not think but no
doubt the girl and her father were used
to it and no doubt it came from the
stagnant water of the canal and from the
rotting wood of the old half sunken boat
that was their refuge my heart throbbed
with pity again their refuge what a
place and my clearer vision of the girls
showed me that she was pitifully thin
even though possessed of the strange
face that drew me to her her clothes
hung around her like old rags but hers
was no scarecrow aspect although little
flesh clothed her bones her very bones
were beautiful I was sure the little
pale heart-shaped face would be more
beautiful still if I could only see it
closely I must see it closely
I must establish some claim to
consideration as a friend of the strange
lonely crew of the half sunken wreck
this is a poor place to call a refuge I
said finally one might have very little
money and yet do somewhat better perhaps
I might help you I'm sure I could if
you're ill treatment in the city was
because of poverty I'm not rich but I
could help that I could help you a
little with money if you would let me or
in any case I could find a position for
you I'm sure I could do that
the eyes that shone fitfully toward me
like two small pools of water
intermittently lit by a cloud swept sky
seemed to glow more brightly she had
been half crouching half sitting on top
of the cabin now she leaped to her feet
with one quick sinuous abrupt motion and
took a few rapid restless steps to and
fro before she answered when she spoke
her voice was a little more than a
whisper yet surely rage was in its
shrill sibilants fool do you think you
would be helping me to tie me to a desk
to shut me behind doors away from
freedom away from the delight of doing
my own will of seeking my own way never
never would I let you do that rather
this old boat rather a deserted grave
under the stars for my home a boundless
surprise swept over me and a positive
feeling of kinship with this strange
being whose face I had hardly seen
possessed me
so I myself might have spoken so I had
often felt though I had never dreamed of
putting my thoughts so definitely so
forcibly my regular eyes daytime life
was a thing I thought little of I really
lived only in my nocturnal prowling
'he's why this girl was right all of
life should be free and spent in places
that interested and attracted how little
how little I knew that night that dread
forces were tugging at my soul were
finding entrance to it an easy access
through the morbid weakness of my nature
how little I knew at what cost I
deviated so radically from my kind who
heard in cities and loved well-lit ways
in the sight of man and sweet and
wholesome places to be solitary in when
the desire for solitude comes over them
that night it seemed to me that there
was but one important thing in life to
allay the angry passion my unfortunate
words had aroused in the breast of my
beloved and to win from her some
answering feeling I understand much
better than you think
I whispered tremulously what I want is
to see you again to come to know you and
to serve you in any way that I may
surely there must be something in which
I can be of use to you all you have to
do from tonight on forever is to command
me I
swear it you swear that you do swear it
delighted at the eagerness of her words
I lifted my hand toward the dark heavens
I swear it from this night on forever I
swear it
then listen tonight you may not come to
me nor I to you I do not want you to
board this boat not tonight not any
night and most of all not any day but do
not look so sad I will come to you no
not tonight perhaps not for many nights
yet before very long I will come to you
there on the bank of the canal when the
water in the canal ceases to flow I must
have made a gesture of impatience or of
despair
it sounded like a way of saying never
for why should the water in the canal
cease to flow she read my thoughts in
some way for she answered them you do
not understand I am speaking seriously I
am promising to meet you there on the
bank and soon for the water within these
banks is moving slower always slower
higher up I have heard that the canal
has been drained between these lower
locks the water still seeps in and
dropped slowly slowly downstream but
there will come a night when it will be
quite quite stagnant and on that night I
will come to you and when I come I will
ask of you a favour and you will keep
your oath it was all the assurance I
could get that night she had come back
to the side of the cabin where she had
sat crouched before and she resumed
again that posture and sat still in
silent watching me sometimes I could see
her eyes upon me and sometimes not but I
felt that their gaze was unwavering the
little cold breeze which I had finally
forgotten while I was talking with her
was blowing again and the unwholesome
smell of decay grew heavier before the
dawn she would not speak again nor
answer me when I spoke to her and I grew
nervous and strangely ill at ease
at last I went away and in the first
faint light of dawn I slipped up the
stairs of my rooming house and into my
own room I was deadly tired at the
office next day and day after day
slipped away and I grew more and more
weary for a man cannot wake day and
night without suffering especially in
hot weather and that was what I was
doing I haunted the old towpath and
waited
night after night on the bank opposite
the sunken boat sometimes I saw my lady
of the darkness and sometimes not when I
saw her she spoke little but sometimes
she sat there on top of the cabin and
let me watch her till the dawn or until
the strange uneasiness that was like
fright drove me from her and back to my
room where I tossed restlessly in the
heat and dreamed strange dreams half
waking till the Sun shone in on my
forehead and I tumbled into my clothes
and down to the office again once I
asked her why she had made the fanciful
condition that she would not come ashore
to meet me until the waters of the canal
had ceased to run how eagerly I studied
those waters how I stole away at
noontime more than once not to approach
the old boat but to watch the almost
imperceptible downward drift of bubbles
bits of straw twigs and rubbish my
questioning displeased her and I asked
her that no more it was enough that she
chose to be whimsical my part was to
wait it was more than a week later that
I questioned her again this time on a
different subject and after that I
curbed my curiosity relentlessly never
speak to me of things you do not
understand about me never again I will
not show myself to you again and when I
walk on the path yonder it will not be
with you I had asked her what form of
persecution she and her father had
suffered in the city that had driven
them out to this lonely place and where
in the city they had lived frightened
seriously lest I lose the ground I was
sure I had gained with her I was about
to speak of something else but before I
could find the words her low voice came
to me again
it was horrible horrible those little
houses below the bridge those houses
along the canal tell me are they not
worse than my boat life there was shut
in and furtive I was not free as I am
now and the freedom I will soon have
will make me forget the things I have
not yet forgotten the screaming the
reviling and cursing fear and flight as
you pass back by those houses think how
you would like to be shut in one of them
and in fear of your life and then think
of them no more for I would forget them
and I will never speak of them again I
dared not answer her I was surprised
that she had vouchsafed me so much but
surely her words meant this that before
she had come to live on the decaying
water rotted old boat she had lived in
one of those horrible houses I passed by
on my way to her those houses each of
which looked like the predestined scene
of a murder
as I left her that night I felt that I
was very daring one or two nights more
and you will walk beside me I called to
her I have watched the water at noon and
it hardly moves at all
I threw a scrap of paper into the canal
and it whirled and swung a little where
a thin skin of oil lay on the water down
there oil from the big dirty city you're
well out of but though I watched and
watched I could not see it move downward
at all perhaps tomorrow night or the
night after you will walk on the bank
with me I hope it will be clear in
moonlight and I will be near enough to
see you clearly as well as you seem
always to see me in darkness or
moonlight equally well and perhaps I
will kiss you but not unless you let me
and yet the next day for the first time
my thoughts were definitely troubled I
had been living in a dream I began to
speculate concerning the end of the path
on which my feet were set I had
conceived from the first such a horror
of those old houses by the canal they
were well enough to walk past nursing
gruesome thoughts for a midnight treat
but much as I loved all that was weird
and eerie about the girl I was wooing so
strangely it was a little too much for
my fancy that she had come from them
by this time I had become decidedly
unpopular in my place of business not
that I had made enemies but that my
peculiar ways had caused too much
adverse comment it would have taken very
little I think to have made the entire
office force decide that I was mad after
the events of the next 24 hours and
after this letter is found in red they
will be sure that they knew it all along
at this time however they were
punctiliously polite to me and merely
let me alone as much as possible which
suited me perfectly I dragged wearily
through day after day exhausted for lack
of sleep conscious of their speculative
glances living only for the night to
come but on this day I approached the
man who had invited me to the camp
across the river who had unknowingly
shown me the way that led to my love
have you ever noticed the row of tumble
down houses along the canal on the city
side I asked him he gave me an odd look
I suppose he sensed the significance of
my breaking silence after so long to
speak of them since that in some way I
had a deep interest in them you have odd
tastes Morton he said after a moment I
suppose you wander into strange places
sometimes I've heard you speak of an
enthusiasm for graveyards at night but
my advice to you is to keep away from
those houses there unsavory and their
reputation is unsavory positively I
think you'd be in danger of your life if
you go poking around there they have
been the scene of several murders and a
dope den or two has been cleaned out of
them why in the world you should want to
investigate them I don't expect to
investigate them I said testily I was
merely interested in them from the
outside to tell you the truth I'd heard
a story a rumor never mind where but you
say there have been murders there I
suppose this rumor I heard may have had
something to do with an attempted one
there was a girl who lived there with
her father once and they were set upon
there or something of the sort and had
to run away did you ever hear that story
Barrett gave me an odd look such as one
gives and speaking of a past horror so
dreadful that the mere speaking of it
makes it live terribly again
what you say reminds me of a horrible
thing that was said to have happened
down there once he said it was in all
the papers
a little child disappeared in one of
those houses and a couple of poor
lodgers who live there a girl and her
father were accused of having made away
with it they were accused well I don't
like to talk about such things it was
too dreadful the child's body was found
part of it was found it was mutilated
and the people in the house seemed to
believe it had been mutilated in order
to conceal the manner of its death there
was an ugly wound in the throat it
finally came out and it seemed as if the
child might have been bled to death it
was found in the girls room hidden away
the old man and his daughter escaped
before the police were called the
countryside was scoured for them the
whole country was scoured but they were
never found why you must have read it in
the papers several years ago I nodded
with a heavy heart I had read it in the
papers I remembered now and again a
terrible questioning came over me who
was this girl what was this girl who
seemed to have my heart in her keeping
why did not a merciful God let me die
then be fogged with exhaustion bemused
in a dire enchantment my mind was
incapable of thought and yet some soul
process akin to that which saves the
sleepwalker poised at perilous heights
sounded its warning now my mind was
filled with doleful images there were
women I had heard in read who slew to
satisfy a bloodlust there were ghosts
specters call them what you will their
names have been legion in the dark pages
of that lore which dates back to the
infancy of the races of the earth who
retained even in death this bloodlust
vampires they had been called that I had
read of them corpses by day spirits of
evil by night roaming abroad in their
own forms are in the forms of bats or
unclean beasts killing body and soul of
their victims for whoever dies of the
repeated kiss of the vampire which
leaves its mark on the throat and draws
the blood from the body becomes a
vampire also
of such beings I had read and horror of
Horrors and that last cursed day at the
office
I remembered reading of these vampires
these undead that in their nocturnal
flights they had one limitation they
could not cross running water that night
I went my usual nightly way with tears
of weakness on my face for my weakness
was supreme and I recognized fully at
last the misery of being the victim of
an enchantment stronger than my feeble
will but I went I approached the
neighbourhood of the canal boat as the
distant city clock chimed the first
stroke of 12:00 it was the dark of the
Moon and the sky was overcast heat
lightning flickered low in the sky
seeming to come from every point of the
compass and circumscribed the horizon as
if unseen fires burned behind the rim of
the world by its fitful glimmer I saw a
new thing between the old boat in the
canal bank stretched a long slim solid
looking shadow a plank had been let down
in that moment I realized that I had
been playing with powers of evil which
had no intent now to let me go which
were indeed about to lay hold upon me
with an inexorable grasp why had I come
tonight why but that the spell of the
enchantment laid upon me was a thing
more potent and far more unbreakable
than any wholesome spell of love the
creature I saw it out
oh I remembered now with the cold
perspiration beating my brow the lure
hidden away between the covers of the
dark old book which I had read so many
years ago and half forgotten until dim
memories of it stirred within me this
last day and night my lady of the night
no woman of wholesome flesh and blood
and odd perverted tastes that matched my
own but one of the undead in that moment
I knew it and knew that the vampires of
old legends polluted still in these
latter days the fair surface of the
earth and on that instant behind me in
the darkness that was a crackle of a
twig and something brushed against my
arm
this then was the fulfillment of my
dream I knew without turning my head
that the pale dainty face with its
glowing eyes was near my own that I had
only to stretch out my arm to touch the
slender grace of the girl I had so long
to draw near I knew and should have felt
the rapture I had anticipated
instead the roots of my hair prickled
coldly unendurable as they had on the
night when I had first sighted the old
vote the miasmic odors of the night
heavy and oppressive with heat and
unrelieved by a breath of air all but
overcame me and I fought with myself to
prevent my teeth clicking in my head the
little waves of coldness I had felt
often in this spot were chasing over my
body yet they were not from any breeze
the leaves on the trees hung down
motionless as though they were actually
wilting on their branches with an effort
I turned my head to hands caught me
around my neck the pale face was so near
that I felt the warm breath from its
nostrils Fanning my cheek and suddenly
all that was wholesome in my perverted
nature rose uppermost I longed for the
touch of the red mouth like a dark
flower opening before me in the night I
longed for it and yet more I dreaded it
shrank back catching it a powerful grip
the fragile wrists of the hands that
strove to hold me I must not I must not
yield to the faintness that I felt
stealing languorous lay over me I was
facing down the path toward the city a
low rumble of thunder the first broke
the torrid hush of the summer night a
glare of lightnings seemed to tear the
night asunder to light up the whole
universe overhead the clouds were
careening madly and fantastic shapes
driven by a wind that swept the upper
heavens without as yet causing even a
trembling in the air lower down and far
down the canal that baleful glare seemed
to play around and hover over the little
row of shanties murder cursed and
haunted by the ghost of a dead child my
gaze was fixed on them while I held away
from me the pallid face and fought off
the embrace that sought to overcome by
resisting will and so a long moment
passed
the glare fainted out of the sky and a
greater darkness took the world but
there was an ear more menacing glare
fastened upon my face the glare of two
eyes that watched mine that had watched
me as I on thinking stared down at the
dark houses this girl this woman who had
come to me and my own importunate
requests did not love me since I had
shrunk from her she did not love me but
it was not only that she had watched me
as I gaze down at the houses that held
her dark past and I was sure that she
divined my thoughts she knew my horror
of those houses she knew my newborn
horror of her and she hated me for it
hated me more malignantly than I had
believed a human being could hate and at
that point in my thoughts I felt my skin
prickle and my scalp rise again could a
human being cherish such hatred as I
read trembling more and more in those
glowing fires lit with what seemed to me
more like the fires of hell than any
light that ought to shine in a woman's
eyes and through all this not a word had
passed between us so far I have written
calmly I wish that I could write on so
to the end if I could do that there
might be one or two of those who will
regard this as the document of a maniac
who would believe the horrors of which
I'm about to write but I am only flesh
and blood at this point in the
happenings of the awful night my
calmness deserted me at this point I
felt that I had been drawn into the
midst of a horrible nightmare from which
there was no escape no waking as I write
this feeling again overwhelms me until I
can hardly write at all until were it
not for the thing which I must do I
would rush out into the street and run
screaming until I was caught and dragged
away to be put behind strong iron bars
perhaps I would feel safe there perhaps
I know that terrified at the hate I saw
confronting me in those redly gleaming
eyes I would have slunk away the two
thin hands that caught my arm again were
strong enough to prevent that however
I had been spared her kiss I was not to
escape from the oath I had taken to
serve her you promised
you swore she hissed in my ear and
tonight you are to keep your oath I felt
my senses real my oath yes I had an oath
to keep I had lifted my hand toward the
dark heavens and sworn to serve her in
any way she chose freely and of my own
volition I had sworn I sought to evade
her let me help you back to your boat I
begged you have no kindly feeling for me
and you have seen it I love you no
longer I will go back to the city you
can go back to your father and forget
that I broke your peace the laughter
that greeted my speech I shall never
forget not in the depths under the
scummy surface of the canal not in the
empty places between the worlds where my
tortured soul may wander so you do not
love me and I hate you fool
have I waited these weary months for the
water to stop only to go back now after
my father and I have returned here and
found the old boat rotting in the drain
canal and took refuge in it when the
water was turned into the canal while I
slept so that I could never escape until
its flow should cease because of the
thing that I am even then I dreamed of
tonight when the imprisonment we still
shared ceased to matter to my father
come on board the deserted boat tomorrow
and see why if you dare
still I dreamed on of tonight I have
been lonely desolate starving now the
whole world shall be mine and by your
help I asked her somehow what she wanted
of me and a madness overcame me so that
I hardly heard her reply yet somehow I
knew that there was that on the opposite
shore of the great river where the
pleasure camps were that she wanted to
find in the madness of my terror she
made me understand and obey her I must
carry her in my arms across the long
bridge over the river deserted in the
small hours of the night
the way back to the city was long
tonight long she walked behind me and I
turned my eyes neither to right nor left
only as I passed the tumble down houses
I saw their reflection in the canal and
trembled so that I could have fallen to
the ground at the thoughts of the little
child this woman had been accused of
slaying there and at the certainty I
felt that she was reading my thoughts
and now the horror that engulfed me
darkened my brain I know that we set our
feet upon the long wide bridge that
spanned the river I know the storm broke
there so that I battled for my footing
almost for my life it seemed against the
pelting deluge and the horror I had
invoked was in my arms clinging to me
burying its head upon my shoulder so
increasingly dreadful had my pale face
companion become to me that I hardly
thought of her now as a woman at all
only as a demon of the night the tempest
rage still as she leaped down out of my
arms on the other Shore and again I
walked with her against my will while
the trees lashed their branches madly
around me showing the pale undersides of
their leaves and the vivid frequent
flashes that rent the heavens on and on
we went branches flying through the air
and missing us by a miracle of ill
fortune such as she and I are not slain
by fallen branches the river was a
welter of Whitecaps flattened down into
strange shapes by the pounding rain the
clouds as we glimpse them were like
Devils flying through the sky past dark
tent after dark tent we stole and passed
a few where lights burned dimly behind
their canvas walls and at last we came
to an old quarry into an artificial
ravine she led me and up to a crevice in
the rock wall reach in your hand and
pull out the loose stone you will feel
she whispered it closes an opening that
leads into deep caverns a human hand
must remove that stone your hand must
move it
why did I struggle so to disobey her why
did I fail it was as though I knew but
my failure was foreordained I had taken
an oath if you who read have believed
that I have set down the truth thus far
the little that is left you will call
the ravings of a madman overtaken by his
madness yet these things happened I
stretched out my arm driven by a
compulsion I could not resist at arm's
length in the niche in the rock
I felt something move the loose rock a
long narrow fragment much larger than I
had expected
yet it moved easily seeming to swing on
a natural pivot outward it swung
toppling toward me a moment more and
there was a swift rush of the ponderous
weight I had loosened I leapt aside and
went down my forehead grazed by the rock
for a brief moment I must have been
unconscious but only for a moment my
head is stabbing agony of pain unreal
lights flashing before my eyes I yet
knew the reality of the storm that beat
me down as I struggled to my feet I knew
the reality of the dark loathsome shapes
that passed me in the dark crawling out
of the orifice and the rock and flapping
through the wild night along the way
that led to the pleasure camps so the
caverns I had laid open to the outer
world were infested with bats I had been
inside unlit caverns and had heard their
the squeaking of the things felt and
heard the flapping of their wings but
never in all my life before had I seen
bats as large as men and women sick and
dizzy from the blow on my head and from
disgust I crept along the way they were
going if I touched one of them I felt
that I should die of horror now at last
the storm abated and a heavy darkness
made the whole world seem like the
inside of a tomb where the tent stood in
a long row the number of the monster
bats seemed to diminish
It was as though horrible thought they
were creeping into the tents with their
slumbering occupants at last I came to a
lighted tent and paused crouching so
that the dim radiance that shone through
the canvas did not touch me in the
shadows
and there I waited but not for long
there was a dark form silhouetted
against the tent a movement of the flap
of the tent a rustle and confusion and
the dark thing was again in silhouette
but with a difference in the quality of
the shadow the dark thing was inside the
tent now it's bat wings extending across
the entrance through which it had crept
fear held me spellbound and as I looked
the shadow changed again imperceptibly
so that I could not have told how it
changed but now it was not the shadow of
a bat but of a woman the storm the storm
I'm lost exhausted I crept in here to
beg for refuge until the dawn that low
thrilling sibilant voice to well I knew
it
within the tent I heard a murmur of
acquiescent voices at last I began to
understand
I knew the nature of the woman I had
carried over the river in my arms the
woman who would not even cross the canal
until the water should have ceased
utterly to flow I remembered books I had
read Dracula other books and stories I
knew they were true books and stories
now I knew those horrors existed for me
I had indeed kept my oath to the
creature of darkness I had brought her
to her kind under her guidance I had let
them loose and hordes upon the pleasure
camps the campers were doomed and
through them others I forgot my fear I
rushed from my hiding-place up to the
tent door and there I screamed and
called aloud don't take her in don't let
her stay nor the others that have crept
into the other tents wake all the
campers they will sleep on to their
destruction drive out the interlopers
drive them out quickly they are not
human no they are not bats do you hear
me do you understand I was fairly
howling in a voice that was strange to
me she is a vampire they are all
vampires inside the tent I heard a new
voice what can be the matter with that
poor man the voice said it was a woman's
and gentle crazy somebody out of his
senses dear a man's voice answered don't
be frightened
and then the voice I knew so well so
well I saw falling rock strike a man on
the head in the storm he staggered away
but I suppose it crazed him
I waited for no more I ran away madly
through the night and back across the
bridge to the city next day today I
boarded the sunken canal boat it is the
abode of death no woman could have lived
there only such a one as she the old
man's corpse was there he must have died
long long ago the smell of death that of
decay on the boat was dreadful again I
felt that I understood back in those
awful houses she had committed the crime
when first she became the things she is
and he her father less sin steeped and
less accursed
attempted to destroy the evidence of her
crime and fled with her but died without
becoming like her she had said that one
of those two was always on watch did he
indeed divide her vigil on the boat what
more fitting the dead standing watch
with the undead and no wonder that she
would not let me board the craft of
death even to carry her away and still I
feel the old compulsion I have been
spared her kiss but for a little while
yet I will not let the power of my oath
to her draw me back till I enter the
caverns with her and creep forth in the
form of a bat to prey upon mankind
before that can happen
I too will die today in the city I heard
that a horde of strange insects or small
animals infested the pleasure camps last
night some said with horror bated breath
that they perhaps were rats none of them
was seen but in the morning nearly every
camper had a strange deep wound in his
throat I almost laughed aloud they were
so horrified at the idea of an army of
rats creeping into the tents and biting
the sleeping occupants on their throats
if they had seen what I saw if they knew
that they are doomed to spread
corruption so my own death will not be
enough today I bought supplies for
blasting tonight I will set my train of
dynamite from the hole I made in the
cliff where the vampires creep in and
out along the row of tents as far as the
last one then I shall light my fuse it
will be done before the
on tomorrow the city will mourn its dead
and execrate my name and then at last in
the slime beneath the unmoving waters of
the canal I shall find peace but perhaps
it will not be peace for I shall seek it
midway between the old boat with its
cargo of death and the row of dismal
houses were a little child was done to
death when first she became the thing
she is that is my expiation
you